how did world war one start
on the one hand world war one started uh
because of a series of events in the
summer of 1914
that brought
sort of the major powers of europe into
conflict with one another but i actually
think it's more useful
to say that world war one started at
least a generation earlier
when
rising powers particularly germany
started devoting more and more of their
resources toward military affairs and
naval affairs this sets off an arms race
in europe it sets off a rivalry
over the colonial world and who will
control the resources in africa and asia
and so by the time you get to the summer
of 1914
and in a lot of ways i say the war has
already begun and this is just the match
that lights the flame so the capacity
for war was brewing within like the the
leaders and within the populace they
started accepting
sort of slowly through the culture
propagated this idea
that
we can go to war
it's a good idea to go to war
it's a good idea to
expand and dominate others that kind of
thing maybe not put in those clear terms
but just the sense that military action
is the way that nations operate at the
global scale
yes yes and right so yes um there's a
sense that the military can be the
solution to political conflict uh in
europe itself
and the and is that war and military
conflict are already happening right
that there's war particularly in africa
in north africa in the middle east you
know balkans conflict is already
underway
and
the european powers haven't faced off
against each other they've usually faced
off against an asymmetrical conflict
against much less powerful states
but you know in some ways that that war
is already underway
so do you think
it was inevitable because world war one
is brought up as a case study where it
seems like uh
a few
accidental leaders and a few accidental
events or one accidental event led to
the war and if you change that one
little thing it could have avoided the
war your senses
the the the drums of war have been
beating for quite a while and it would
have happened almost no matter what or
very likely to have happened yes
historians never like to say things are
inevitable um and certainly you know
there were people who could have chosen
a different path both in the short term
and the long term um but fundamentally
um there were
irreconcilable conflicts in the system
of empires in the world in 1914
uh i can't see uh you know it didn't
have to be this war but it had it
probably had to be a war so there was
the german empire the austro-hungarian
empire
there was france and great britain
us
could usp call that empire at that
moment yet
when do you graduate to empire status um
well certainly after after 1898 with the
acquisition of the former territories of
the spanish empire you know the united
states has formal colonial possessions
um and it has sort of mindsets of of
rule and military acquisition that would
define em empire in a kind of more
informal sense so you would say you
would put the blame
or the responsibility
of starting world war one into the hands
of the german empire and kaiser wilhelm
ii
you know
that's a really uh tough call to make
and you know that deciding that is going
to keep historians in business for the
next 200 years and
i think
there
are people who would lay all of the
blame um uh on the germans right and you
know who would point toward a generation
of arms buildup um you know alliances
that that germany made and promises that
they made to
to their allies in the balkans to the
austro-hungarians
and so yes there's an awful lot of
responsibility there
there has been a trend lately to say
no it's no one's fault
right that uh you know that all of the
various powers literally were
sleepwalking into the war right they
backed into it inadvertently
i think that lets everyone a little too
much off the hook right and so i think
in between
is uh you know i would put the blame on
the system of empires itself on the
system
but in that system the actor that sort
of carries the most responsibility is
definitely imperial germany so the
leader of ultra hungarian empire france
joseph the first
his nephew's archduke franz ferdinand he
was assassinated
and
so that
didn't have to lead to a war
and then
the the leader of the german empire
geyser wilhelm ii
pressured sort of
uh
started talking trash
um and
boiling the water that ultimately
resulted in the explosion
um plus all the other players so what
can you describe the dynamics of how
that unrolled well us what's the role of
u.s what's the rule of france what's the
role of great britain germany and also
hungarian empire
yeah over the course of about uh four
weeks right following the assassination
of uh of the archduke in sarajevo
um it sort of triggers a series of
political conflicts and ultimately
ultimatums
sort of demanding
sort of that that one or other power
sort of stand down in response to to the
demands of either
you know britain france or or in turn
germany or russia at the same time that
those alliances kind of trigger
automatic responses um from the other
side and so it escalates um and once
that escalation is combined with the
call up of military troops
then none of those powers wants to be
sort of the last one to kind of get
ready for conflict so even throughout it
they are they think they are getting
ready in a defensive
maneuver
and they if they think if there is
conflict well it might be a skirmish it
might be you know sort of a standoff
uh it could be solved with diplomacy
later because diplomacy is failing now
that turns out not to be the case
diplomacy fails it's not a skirmish it
becomes a massive war and the americans
are watching all of this from the
sidelines they have very little
influence over what happens that summer
how does it go from a skirmish between a
few nations
to a global war
is there a place where there's a phase
transition
yeah i think the phase transition is in
over the course of the fall of 1914
when the germans make an initial sort of
bold move into france
in many ways they're fighting the last
war the franco-prussian war of 18 of
1870 um and they really do sort of um
you know kind of want to
have a quick sort of uh lightning strike
in some ways against france um to kind
of bring the war to a speedy conclusion
uh france turns out to be able to fight
back more effectively than the germans
expected
um and then uh the battle lines sort of
harden
and then behind that uh the the the
french and the germans as well as the
british on on the side of the french
start digging in literally right and
digging trenches trenches that at first
are you know
three feet deep to you know to avoid
shelling from artillery then become six
feet ten feet deep you know two miles
wide um that include telegraph wires
that include whole hospitals in the back
and then at that point um you know the
the front is is locked in place and the
only way to break that is sort of
basically dialing the war up to 11.
right sort of massive numbers of troops
massive efforts um
none of which work right and so the war
is stuck in this but that's the that's
the phase transition right there
what were the machines of war
in that case you mentioned trenches what
were the guns used
what was the size of guns what are we
talking about what what did germany
start
accumulating that led up to this war
one of the things that we see
immediately
is the industrial revolution of the
previous 30 or 40 years
brought uh to bear on warfare
right and so you see sort of machine
guns you see artillery uh you know these
are the kind of the the key weapons of
war on both sides right the vast
majority of battlefield casualties are
from artillery shelling from one side to
another um not you know sort of rifle or
or even sort of you know machine gun
kind of uh attacks
in some ways the the weapons of war are
are human beings right um you know tens
of thousands of them poured over the top
um in these sort of waves to kind of try
to break through the enemy lines and it
would work for a little while um you
know but but holding the territory that
had been gained often proved to be
even more demanding than than gaining it
and so often
um you know each side would retreat back
into the trenches and wait for another
day
and how did
russia
how did britain
how did
france get pulled into the war i suppose
the france one is the easy one but what
what is the order of events here right
it becomes a global war yeah so britain
france and and russia uh are at this
time and
they're an alliance um and so the
the conflicts you know in the summer of
1914 that lead uh sort of to the
declarations of war happened sort of one
after another right um at the in august
of in late august of 1914
um and all three powers essentially come
in at the same time
because they have promised to do so um
through a series of alliances um
conducted secretly in the years before
1914 that committed them to defend one
another
germany austria hungary and the ottoman
empire have their own sort of set of
secret uh agreements that also commit
them to defend one another um and what
this does is it sort of brings them all
into into conflict at the exact same
moment they're also for many of these
countries bringing not just their their
national armies uh but also their
empires into the conflict right so
britain and france of course have you
know enormous uh sort of global empires
they begin mobilizing soldiers as well
as raw materials
germany uh has you know less of an
overseas empire russia and the ottoman
empire of course have their own sort of
hinterland um you know within the empire
and very soon you know sort of all of
the warring powers are are bringing the
entire world into into the conflict did
they have a sense of how deadly the war
is i mean this is another
scale of death and destruction
at the beginning no but very quickly
the scale of the devastation of these
sort of massive over-the-top
attacks on trenches is apparent to the
military officers and it very quickly
becomes apparent even at home
you know there is of course censorship
of the battlefield and and you know
specific details don't reach people
but you know for civilians and in any of
the the warring powers they know fairly
soon how destructive the war is
uh and to me that's always been a real
sort of um
puzzle
right so that by the time the united
states comes to decide whether to join
the war in 1917
they know what exactly what they're
getting into right they're not backing
into the war in the ways that the
european powers did
you know they've seen the devastation
they've seen photographs
they've seen injured soldiers
and they make that choice anyway when
you say they do you mean the leaders of
the people did
the
the death and destruction reach the
minds of the american people by that
time uh yes absolutely you know that the
we don't in 1917 have the mass media
that we have now but
but you know there are images in
newspapers there are newsreels that play
at the movie theaters
and of course some of it is sanitized
but
but that combined with press accounts
often really quite descriptive press
accounts um gory accounts reached you
know anyone who cared to read them you
know certainly plenty of people didn't
follow the news felt it was far away but
but most americans who cared about the
news knew how devastating this war was
you